last year was the deadliest year on
record for Mexico drug-related violence
has infiltrated all parts of society and
all parts of the country it's affecting
everyone and it is absolutely everywhere
Acapulco was somewhere at the center of
some of the worst violence in the
country
our story was the influence of the crime
gangs how their their tentacles have
spread out across the country and
Acapulco is a good example of it so we
you asked the police if we can go along
when a police patrol
well the CIA's latest travel advisories
for a number of areas in Mexico but
particularly here is don't even bother
going if you're a tourist reason for
that they say is that the murder rate
the danger levels are so high they're
actually comparable to Iraq and Syria
and indeed here in one month last year
over two thousand people were murdered
in these drug wars on this patrol we
arrived at a village a small town and it
was a bizarre experience we came across
a crime scene where less than 24 hours
previously eight people had been killed
[Music]
okay so this is your goes a little model
so this is where somebody's been killed
right so one person here another one
here there we still bullet holes
everywhere there was blood splatters on
the floor another here and other there
there's all these little flowers and
candles that had been left on the spots
where people that had died only just
recently the last of the crime scenes is
here then you can see the bullet holes
from the shooting take place here that's
eight in total so this is a pretty big
an organized hit they actually went from
person to person I mean these were
actual shooting individual two not just
this but actually wenton so they were
hiding yeah it was pretty shocking to
see their families their wives their
mums their sisters really traumatized it
was very very sad there was a lot of
grief and that people were upset by what
they had seen and they wanted justice
[Music]
they said is no first time this is my
second this my turkey became all my
family in junetta
it's a conflict so it's really bad you
feel I feel really really sad when we
were only left
[Music]
it's a level of brutality and tragedy
that is very very difficult to get your
head round when you come from a society
like I live in
imagine is something like that happened
in sorry on Hackney or to be in the
newspapers all over the UK and she is
just something little next day I won't
remember
we don't decided to try and get to
actually the people who make the stuff
that fuels all of the problems we were
taken up into the mountains to a modest
house with a big front porch and now we
were introduced to a guy who is clearly
in charge he said Farmers Union
I mean it's open to interpretation Wien
just arrived this has been worked on for
a long period of time contacts have to
be made they don't know who you are they
might think that you're undercover
American Drug Enforcement by just
putting ourself in a really stupid
situation where they can kill us
these guys don't see themselves as
gangsters they actually just seen
themselves as businessmen and farmers
the guy Chad wouldn't admit to farming
opium but he did say he farmed what he
farmed to survive
una familia grande para Dogon tradition
Brasilia Tomatis tiene que I will color
the Ottoman era
one of the first tales he told us when
we started talking to him was about how
he had been arrested but this wasn't an
ordinary arrest three blackhawk
helicopters had turned up this doesn't
happen for just anybody
Fiona Orden
there are amazing Kanaka no he's not an
ordinary male Adelina Latino I'm selling
a second
they may look very normal but they are
involved in a very very dangerous
business
in many ways they were a bit like the
Mexican Sopranos if you like he was very
affable but there was no forgetting that
this is a serious character and though
this was essentially an interview but we
were the ones being interviewed I've
been having lunch with many of these
farmers and they are just really lovely
and nice people they had to kill you
they kill you but no we're good friends
to each other he made phone call we were
allowed to go up into the jungle where
we met by security guys carrying machine
guns fully kitted out with their faces
with bandanas and they took us to the
poppy food
[Music]
after about half an hour of really rough
terrain we arrived into this opening it
looked like the middle of the forest had
just been completely opened up so that
they could grow the poppies
so this is the hobby aisle that becomes
opium and eventually that becomes arrow
in a morphine er yeah and all this field
having this weather's perfect for it and
it just keeps producing so it's a
brilliant crop or why wouldn't the
demand is so high and as long as the
demand is high and we know the biggest
user is the United States then it's
going to keep being made they know what
happened when you ask them you know that
with this they create Harry yes and you
know that that create lots of problems
yes but for us it's just another product
data mandals avocado we grew up cattle
it seems interesting that what happens
here and then what happens say in
Acapulco yeah they're linked but nobody
thinks about it right now this is what
we have to do we have no other option I
remember one farmer Tammy yeah I know
that this is poison but if I don't
create this poison my family's doing
today so it's a chicken and egg
speaking to them it was pretty clear
that they considered there was real
threat from rival gangs coming in to
take their crop and we don't have a gun
to protect us they will kill us
[Music]
nobody knows how much money is made by
the drug cartels but it is billions and
billions and billions and billions of
dollars and it's nationwide
it's absolutely every city every town
every village in varying levels of
[Music]
either involvement in the drugs or
involvement in crime that is actually
perpetuated by this whole society where
criminality is completely normal
if you think like a lengthy Armenian
anthe we went to meet a guy who's a
hitman
then more widely empathy you know he
explained to us in in detail the hits
that he's carrying out do you have a
parent presence or the Posada over they
can open in media there a link went up
of a philosophy you have business rivals
now not cartels hiring this guy to take
out rivals can take because it's cool an
but uh you know para para services that
area thinking of can impunity
if I need to fix something in my
business and I think that my partner is
a steaming part of my money
I just called this guy the businessman
he's working for business women as he
was keen to point out will actually ask
for really horrible things hands curve
heads cut off
it's a completely different level off
the scale violence he interestingly saw
absolutely no reason to feel any type of
remorse and although he's quite pleasant
in his pleasant to us he's a very very
dangerous individual
[Music]
violence throughout this society has
become the norm it really is a mess and
everybody we speak to doesn't see an
entry in fact they see it getting worse
the problem is so big and so ingrained
is it actually possible to sort out it's
a become part of society the crime
levels and the sheer amount of money
that's available from crime is
guaranteeing that Mexico's not suffer
for a very very long time
[Music]